Traduttore: Antonella Santelia
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Dal pesce al filosofo.
Questo è un bellissimo libro
di Homer Smith,
pubblicato a Boston nei primi anni '50.
Homer Smith è stato un grande fisiologo.
La maggior parte delle cose che
noi pensiamo di scoprire in laboratorio
si trova nei suoi libri,
uno più bello dell'altro.
In questo c'è scritto che
‘ciascuno di noi non è quello che mangia,
ma è quello che il suo rene
è capace di conservare’.
A cosa servono i reni?
A produrre urina, direte voi. Giusto.
Ma il rene ha tante altre funzioni ancora.
È per il rene che noi viviamo qui,
a dispetto dell'ambiente.
A noi sembra normale
di vivere sulla Terra.
Ma la Terra è ostile alla vita,
almeno lo era,
e per certi versi lo è ancora.
Noi siamo fatti per due terzi di acqua.
Le nostre cellule
sono immerse in un fluido
che ha e deve avere
una composizione ben precisa.
Ecco, la funzione principale
del rene è proprio questa:
di mantenere la composizione del fluido
che bagna le cellule precisa.
Basta un poco più di sodio, Na+,
o un po' meno,
perché il cervello ne soffra.
E il potassio?
Se il potassio aumenta, si ferma il cuore.
Non preoccupatevi.
C’è il vostro rene,
e voi non lo sapete neppure.
È il rene che ci dà
la capacità di eccedere.
Il rene poi sa, straordinariamente,
eliminare tutto quello che è in eccesso.
Noi possiamo prendere
quanto c’è in eccesso
- acqua e sale, per esempio -
e il rene elimina ciò che non serve.
E lo fa minuto per minuto
con una precisione
che nessuna bilancia,
di nessun farmacista,
sarebbe in grado di fare.
È il rene quindi che ci permette
di riuscire a superare il superfluo.
Ma se il rene smette
di funzionare improvvisamente,
noi moriamo nel giro di pochi giorni.
È perché le sostanze di scarto che noi
ogni giorno produciamo sono tossiche.
Ma il rene si adatta
anche molto bene al danno.
Possiamo anche avere una riduzione
della funzione del rene fino all’80 - 85%
e stare ancora abbastanza bene.
E dopo?
C'è la dialisi.
Ma la dialisi non sostituisce
tutte le funzioni del rene.
Non quella per esempio
di contribuire a produrre globuli rossi
attraverso l’eritropoietina.
Né quella di proteggere le ossa
con la vitamina D.
Senza i reni saremmo un po' rachitici.
Quante persone vivono con la dialisi?
Circa 2 milioni di persone al mondo.
E per loro spendiamo
più di 1000 miliardi di dollari.
Una cifra pazzesca, enorme.
Le persone in dialisi sono soprattutto
negli Stati Uniti, in Europa,
in Giappone, in Australia.
Il 90% dei dializzati è lì.
Nell'altra parte del mondo, nei paesi
emergenti, la dialisi è poca o nulla.
Ma lì vivono 5 miliardi di persone.
Per un certo verso,
la dialisi è per i paesi ricchi.
Fare in modo che questo non sia più così
è stata una grande sfida
per tutto il mondo e per tutti noi.
Ed è stato questo
l'impegno di tanti anni di ricerca.
Ma come si arriva alla dialisi?
Vi racconto una storia.
Mario ha 50 anni, è sempre stato bene.
Ad un certo punto fa la visita di leva,
quando era giovane,
e gli trovano del sangue nelle urine
ma nessuno ci fa caso.
Andando avanti negli anni sta sempre bene
fino a che ad un certo punto,
un bel giorno comincia a urinare tanto,
anche di notte, e ha forti mal di testa.
Non ne può più.
Va in farmacia per prendere un analgesico
e il farmacista gli prova la pressione.
Ha 200 su 110.
‘Ma come è possibile?’, fa lui,
‘Ho sempre avuto la pressione normale!’.
Il farmacista lo invita
ad andare al pronto soccorso.
Va al pronto soccorso
e gli fanno una serie di esami.
Ha un’insufficienza renale grave,
dicono i medici.
E dopo due settimane va in dialisi.
4 ore al giorno, 3 giorni su 7,
per tutte le settimane del mese,
per tutti i mesi dell'anno.
E sarà così fino a quando
non ci sarà per lui un trapianto,
un trapianto di rene.
Questa è una storia un po’ come un'altra,
di ipertensione, di diabete,
che alla lunga danneggiano il rene.
E quindi, si è pensato,
quante persone
possono avere una storia analoga?
Sappiamo che il 10 % della popolazione
mondiale ha qualche forma di danno renale
che, se trascurata, progredirà nel tempo.
Ed è quindi molto importante
pensare a questo.
Di solito sono persone
che hanno proteine nelle urine,
soprattutto albumina.
E noi sappiamo dai nostri studi
che l'albumina, anche se poca,
presente nelle urine, prima o poi
darà un danno al rene
e poi anche al cuore.
Per fortuna il rene però
si può proteggere.
Una bellissima notizia,
che voglio condividere con voi.
Ed è un cambiamento.
Rispetto a prima, si pensava
che ci fosse solo la dialisi,
invece c'è la possibilità
di proteggere il rene.
Come?
Con farmaci che abbassano la pressione
e che fanno parte della categoria
degli inibitori dell'enzima
di conversione per l’angiotensina.
Parolone molto difficile.
Sono farmaci che vengono utilizzati,
come si dice in gergo, antipertensivi
e proteggono il rene
dal deterioramento della funzione.
Ma proteggono alla lunga anche il cuore
dall'infarto e dallo scompenso.
È partita proprio da qui,
da Bergamo, questa ricerca
che ha visto un grande
sforzo collaborativo
tra ricercatori, clinici dell'Istituto
Mario Negri e del nostro ospedale.
E da adesso questa terapia
è usata in tutto il mondo.
Anche negli Stati Uniti,
che di solito vengono prima di noi.
Come abbiamo fatto?
(Applausi)
Come abbiamo fatto a scoprire
questa terapia che protegge il rene?
Con l'aiuto degli animali.
Senza topi e ratti non c'è progresso,
si ferma la medicina.
Bisogna che ne siamo consapevoli,
che ognuno di noi lo sappia.
Grazie a questi piccoli roditori
abbiamo capito il rapporto che esiste
tra la perdita della normale
funzione del rene,
il passaggio di albumina, che è tossico,
e la presenza di infiammazione che è
il primo stadio della malattia renale.
Dal topo all'uomo, poi,
il passaggio è stato breve.
Quei farmaci che
erano efficaci nell'animale
sono stati efficacissimi nell'uomo.
Se un paziente non viene
trattato - la riga rossa -
la sua funzione renale
si deteriora nel tempo, si riduce,
fino al punto che ha bisogno
di dialisi o trapianto.
Con i farmaci che abbiamo
studiato e scoperto,
la funzione renale viene mantenuta.
Non si ha una riduzione della funzione
renale, almeno per i primi 3 anni.
E, cosa che non ci aspettavamo,
la funzione renale
addirittura migliora dopo 3 anni.
Perché questo?
Perché è una questione
di cellule staminali.
Con questi farmaci
noi riusciamo a mantenere
il patrimonio di cellule staminali
che ciascuno di noi ha nel proprio rene.
Ce ne sono dappertutto,
le abbiamo in tutti gli organi.
Le abbiamo trovate in tanti distretti.
A Bergamo le abbiamo viste nel rene,
le abbiamo studiate negli animali.
Le abbiamo trovate lì
e le abbiamo trovate anche nell'uomo.
Le abbiamo isolate, come si dice in gergo.
Le abbiamo caratterizzate.
Abbiamo visto che cosa producevano.
Abbiamo visto
quale era il loro potenziale.
Con i farmaci che proteggono il rene
abbiamo mantenuto l'integrità
di tutte queste cellule staminali.
Il risultato è stato che si è fermata
la progressione della malattia renale
e il rene, giorno dopo giorno,
si è riparato.
Così la funzione renale è migliorata.
Certo, per curare la malattia renale,
per fermare la progressione della
malattia renale bisogna partire presto.
Dopo è troppo tardi.
E come si fa?
Basta un semplice esame delle urine.
Basta vedere se abbiamo proteine
e soprattutto albumina nelle urine.
Se l'abbiamo, questo è un segnale.
Bisogna intervenire.
Ma quasi nessuno lo fa,
alle urine non ci si pensa.
C'è poca sensibilità
per le malattie renali.
Se voi pensate il rene è negletto,
anche nel linguaggio popolare.
Si dice ‘cuor di leone’
o ‘uno che ha fegato’
ma non c'è niente di simile per il rene.
Nella Bibbia per un'infinità di volte
si parla di sangue e di cuore
ma di rene una sola volta.
Quando Dio, per giudicare
gli uomini, guarda i loro reni.
Perché i reni erano considerati la sede
del temperamento, delle emozioni
e anche delle virtù.
E poi via via nessuno più parla di reni
nella letteratura fino a Shakespeare.
Fine del 1500,
"Le allegre comari
di Windsor", terzo atto:
Falstaff parla di reni e rivolgendosi
a colui il quale pensa sia un gentiluomo,
che è Master Brook,
gli dice la sua disavventura.
Falstaff si era nascosto
in una cesta di panni sporchi
che era stata buttata nel Tamigi,
e rivolgendosi al gentiluomo dice
(in inglese) ‘a man of my kidneys’.
Letteralmente ‘oh uomo dei miei reni’.
Cioè una persona come me,
col mio temperamento
e forse anche per la mia corporatura.
Se non fosse per il rene,
saremmo ancora negli stagni
e saremmo pesci o ranocchi.
È il rene che ci ha permesso di evolvere,
e ha permesso a certi animali
di lasciare gli oceani e i fiumi
per vivere sulla Terra.
Senza reni, qui sulla Terra,
non ci sarebbero i filosofi.
Grazie per la vostra attenzione.
(Applausi)